as soon as I started seeing kids who
never had an entrepreneurial bone in
their body who'd never sold a thing in
their life who never cared about any of
that stuff and Cobra coming out of
college and starting businesses that's
when I was like 24 months ago that's
when I was like oh this is starting to
get a little awkward I would like to
just read the very last paragraph of
your book so yes this moment is the
happiest in my life because with every
encounter every adventure every
experience ultimately everything always
gets collectively better that is it does
when you choose to focus on the positive
which I definitely do you should try it
so I had my monthly breakfast meeting
with Gary we've been doing this
religiously haven't missed since I've
been here a little over a year we
covered some big topics today including
the structure of our offices our UK
office making some big announcements are
very excited about what 2016 brings for
for this office I told them while I've
spent time in various marketing
companies public relations branding
general market advertising mobile media
I've never been part of something with
this kind of hyper growth so really
exciting and his his vision inspiration
passion is infectious to us all
there's a 10:30 flight from Dulles to
London direct all right like that
I like that get you in at 10:40 in the
world I love that squeaky toy I love I
love that okay cool I love that yeah and
also my other thought was that we didn't
think of this
but Passover is that Friday yeah so that
allows you to get back for Passover
which you have to get back yes yeah so
we're good with that I'll tie this moan
about that um see it seems like you're
feeling okay for dinner tonight I'm
still holding on we'll say okay he's not
buying any bucks I'm not I'm not asking
him yet but I'm gonna send him one
speaking of which I want you to write up
a Gary VIP right now with two items from
the wine room and a PS my new book comes
out in a week I look by you being on
this list I'd like to send you one
please reply to me going on what are we
doing oh I need a coffee where's Joe ROM
oh thank you everybody
yeah thank you how's it going good you
feeling good mmm-hmm super good good man
good luck super well I got invited to
that Nasdaq thing too I tried to come
because I knew you're gonna be there but
couldn't make happy
how are you the field you are you good
uh wrong fortune I'm a musician I'm a
connector I am a cool dude like that got
behind me I'm gonna talk some [ __ ] about
him some ish you could bleep it all I
think he curses on his show I'm talking
about I Gary's a mentor somebody who I
look to you know to get great ideas from
just somebody who's a mentor from afar
and close
really teaching me like this jabbing and
it's right hooking [ __ ] the most
important lesson I learned from him is
probably execution like ideas don't mean
nothing you know if you if you have a
great idea and go do it because ideas
exist in multiple people's heads you
know I'm saying the same ideas so if you
don't go do it somebody else want to do
it
guys great to see you excited take care
of how are you the best I was getting a
ton of questions on Twitter and my
facebook page and so I started the show
with a real goal in mind of one kind of
reentering the public domain you know
from 2011 to 2014 I was pretty head down
building vaynermedia I wasn't putting
out a lot of content I put out Jab Jab
Jab right hook but for the most part I
was very quiet and number two more than
anything I wanted to establish myself as
somebody who could go to conferences and
just do Q&A as the keynote kind of like
a town-hall play and so I am
listen I've consciously created a show
and unconsciously created a book around
this subject matter and the truth is and
I really appreciate your accolades to
the book and I've done this long enough
this is my fourth business book you know
the second and third business book after
crush it Jesus look at the difference in
thickness between this is nuts
holy my friends my admirers my
contemporaries the people that don't
love me as much they no question were
less enthusiastic about thank you
economy in Jab Jab Jab right hook then
what I'm feeling over the last two weeks
of askgaryvee it's very clear to me that
QA puts me and my content in the best
position and in the world that we now
live in I don't know if you felt this
but I've been pumped because people tell
me like that they're consuming the
content in a way that's sticking because
it's kind of like boom boom boom boom
right it's question answer a question
answer a question answer it's not this
drawn-out chapter where you're like wait
a minute what did I just kind of
and uh there's a level of practicality
to the format that I think is uh has
been really powerful
Ali thank you for your time I wish you
well all right
same to you take care thank you bye-bye
it was fun yeah I'm a character I feel
like I'm living like I feel like I'm a
character I don't notice it are we doing
the Oscar V show uh no yeah okay what's
next what's your phone my phone is that
first let me see periscope let me say
what's up to the homies sup homies um my
68 could you put in airplane mode please
one periscoping what's your gun
periscoping is there no Mophie in the
building there is but why do I [ __ ] up
I should told you to grab the mo if you
have the big guy I have one but why not
no cuz I'd rather periscope then
airplane we're gonna periscope for the
next hour
Matt hey Matt tell it tell tell them you
don't want me where's tell them tell
them to their face you're scoping right
now until guys check out mascara Matt
Matt has a glue and a brown eye come on
Matt Chum Chum what's gone is it I
forget as this one right yeah damned if
I had a brown in blue I I would dominate
the erotic
I would be bigger than I am today cuz I
would bring the [ __ ] out of that I have
a t-shirt with the brand you know what I
mean it would just be the two color ah
I'd be so much bigger all right what are
we doing you're filming this oh I'm
filming some stuff for Fox 5 you have a
meeting and then when we get to a scary
the evil Paris all right all right
Matt's in charge sorry guys that's just
you know where he's a bad guy
ha I'm not a bad guy that's [ __ ]
when the money runs out for your next
round an interesting thing happens which
is straight carnage you know I think
that over the last five to seven years
we've seen way too many people build
businesses that are only predicated on
raising money in the next round and have
no practicality then listen you know
this people are raising five ten million
dollars it's three years later and the
business doesn't make any money that's
stupid
and it will work for six award for six
unicorns yeah if you build snapchat and
Facebook and uber yes it will work what
about for the other 90,000 businesses
the alternative is what's happened for a
hundred years prior to venture capital
and technology build something that has
some practicality within 24 months and
borrow money either from a bank or an
individual or a VC firm but go and then
make it profitable instead of making it
attractive for the next race
I have no F I have no empathy
I have no empathy for somebody that's
raised ten million dollars and still is
burning like maybe you don't need to
like LEM Han do you know many goddamn
entrepreneurs right now they're 24 years
old that raise 10 million dollars have
gone skiing the last four weekends in a
row
the alternative is exactly what's
happened the last hundred years which is
those entrepreneurs were so scared that
they were going to default on their
balance at the bank that they worked on
Saturday I can't believe them a little
bit under the weather this is like rare
territory vayniacs
sucks
now I want to make sure and this is
important to me and I appreciate if you
add this I want to have a very strong
Astrakhan caveat in parallel there will
be enormous ly big businesses built to
throwing this climate because the
internet is eating up the world so much
like Amazon and eBay were built during
the web 1.0 burst I you know I very much
am bullish on on Internet consumer web
opportunities I just think that we're
going to have a cleansing of the tier 2
3 4 5 6 7 & 8 entrepreneurs it's an
absolute purging of the posers that's
exactly what's gonna happen right and by
the way it's not because I'm so smart
it's because that's what always happens
when things get too frothy you know and
you know this when used when I know this
as soon as I start seeing kids who never
had an entrepreneurial bone in their
body who'd never sold a thing in their
life who never cared about any of that
stuff and Cobra coming out of college
and starting businesses that's when I
was like 24 months ago that's when I was
like oh this is starting to get a little
awkward I would tell you that I don't
see this as a negative I think that
that's what's great about capitalism and
meritocracy like like like not like not
everybody is supposed to become a
world-class singer or a professional
athlete like the market should have its
repercussions and so and by the way I
think a lot of these kids I actually
think a lot of the kids that are getting
into it now are going to be saved
because instead of wasting four or five
years trying to be a number one they're
going to go and work for Bain and
McKinsey or all these other places right
all these practical businesses and
they'll they'll gain skills the craft
and they'll become more self-aware and
they may they may learn on the next
rodeo that they're not the number
one but they can be a tremendous
president or a tremendous CFO or a
tremendous senior executive and probably
find much more fruitfulness in playing
in the proper position than than the
alternative and to me that's what's
fascinating everybody knows it to be
true if you're willing to just break it
down in simple conversation the problem
is we all got caught up in the reality
of the game instead of the reality of
actual business talk we're a deep
[ __ ] [ __ ] and killed us this is not
good you tell me what happened boss gap
my name is Gary I tell him I tell my
left hand messages and emailed him that
there was a major accident in New York
and I'm 40 minutes late for zero yeah
thank you okay okay you get the message
did you get the message from them okay
and hard streets of Greenwich
Connecticut
great meeting senior execs always fun to
break bread with people that did it
before you at the highest levels now
headed back to New York to jam with some
of my senior team so
I see Orsini and Chris is it I want you
guys go get them I'm just going to
finish right now stop Jason come in wrap
it up the day my homies vaynermedia crew
Markus Ayla we go just so you know
riding under the weather almost midnight
not every day is gonna come super easy
but persevering you know just when the
buck stops with you
just isn't a lot of sick base so not to
say because I always get bang for this
feeling not you're really sick you'd
stay home and rest
but the difference the difference when
it's on you is when you're borderline
sick you grind out of me today
anyway
you